[MUSIC PLAYING]
PUNEITH KAUL: First off,
welcome to Cloud AI Huddle.
My name is Puneith.
And I am on Cloud
AI Engineering team
focused on AI developer option.
And so it's all again about you.
I would like to invite you to
check out two of the links,
the bit.ly/aihuddle, which
the TLDR there is AI Huddle is
the open, collaborative,
developer-first forum,
which is driven by
Google AI expertise.
And this is a forum where you
get connected with Googlers.
And we'll help you
solve your AI problems.
And the second
thing is, which we
launched or announced last
week, was cloudai-office-hours.
It's still in the pilot.
And it's a program where you can
connect or VC, Virtual Content,
with Googlers and talk
through some of your problems
you are facing.
And it's a great
way to get unblocked
in a really quick fashion.
And then also, a quick
shout-out to our entire Cloud
AI community.
We have 950 members
as of yesterday.
And, again, it's a
shout-out to you all.
So thank you so much
for the enthusiasm
and just sort of
continue the momentum
and help us help you
unblock in your AI journey.
With that, I'll hand
it over to Shantanu.
Shantanu, take it over.
SHANTANU PAI: Hi.
I'm Shantanu.
I'm going to do a quick intro,
although Brian is amazing.
I don't know we can cover
all of this quickly.
But Brian Kobashikawa is a
senior interaction designer
on the Cloud AI team at Google.
And the workflows that
you're going to see today
were designed by Brian.
So basically, from the
inception, from scratch,
going from zero to what
you're going to see today,
it's been an amazing journey.
And we launched AutoML
Vision recently.
And so you'll get to
see, to a certain extent,
how we actually arrive at
some of the design decisions.
Brian previously worked in the
Material Design team at Google.
And before that, he's worked
at various US organizations,
including multi-year stints
as the lead visual designer
for Yahoo Mail and
Yahoo Messenger.
Over to you, Brian.
BRIAN KOBASHIKAWA: All right.
Well, thanks very much.
Can everybody hear me OK?
All right.
So, yeah.
I think the agenda
for tonight is going
to be fairly straightforward.
We'll start off with just the
introduction to AutoML Vision
overall.
Then we'll jump into a demo,
hopefully, a live demo.
And then after that,
the part that strikes me
as being the salient
part of my perspective
is the deeper dive into the
user experience or the UX.
And so as a result,
the talk will probably
be a little bit different
than probably previous AI
meetups in that it's
focusing very much
on how product experiences
are designed at Google,
especially this nascent,
emerging AI space
and how we're trying to tackle
the myriad UX challenges that
are present throughout
these experiences.
So first off, let's start
with an introduction
to AutoML Vision.
And to start with that, we have
the mission for the computer
vision group as a whole.
And that's to help developers
build the next generation
computer vision-powered
autonomy solutions.
And so this blue bar over here
represents the area of work
that we're focused on, that
being our pretrained machine
learning APIs and AutoML.
AutoML being-- there
are three products
that launched at Google Next
2018 just a few months ago.
That would be AutoML Vision,
AutoML Natural Language,
and AutoML Translation.
And the foundation for
those ML APIs and AutoML
are the technologies
and research
and the various
decades of work that
have happened on the Google
Machine Perception team.
The investments into TensorFlow
and Cloud-hosted TPUs
drive these sort of development
of these products, which
can then in turn drive a
variety of different use cases.
And those use cases span a
large variety or a large gamut
ranging from energy, like
say, like in the vision case,
like being able to detect spots
of corrosion on a wind turbine,
for example, all the way
to something like retail
where maybe you have
a product catalog
and you want to recognize
objects in photos
that match that catalog.
So as it turns out, the
pretrained machine learning
API, the Vision
API, can actually
address a lot of
those use cases.
So it's a pretrained model.
It has a variety of
different features.
And you can learn more about
it at cloud.google.com/vision.
But the variety of features
that it has are presented here.
These bottom four, on the bottom
right, the Handwriting OCR,
Product search, Object
localizer, and Web detection
were announced at Next
2018 back in July.
But there's a variety
of different use cases
that these features handle,
ranging from optical character
recognition, being able
to scan and transfer
large amounts of paper documents
at scale, to labeling, to logo
detection, image properties
like common colors
or dominant colors.
So the pretrained Vision
API would handle a lot
of these particular cases.
And if you go to the ML API
section on the Cloud website,
you'll see that there's
a Video Intelligence API.
There's a Natural Language
API, Translation API.
Translation API has been
around for a while, actually.
But the question
emerges is, what
happens if the data
that you're looking for
or the objective
that you're going for
belongs to a different
domain and you
need to support these very
specific concepts that may not
necessarily be covered
by the Vision API?
And so probably the answer that
a data scientist might come up
with is that they would create
their own computer vision
model.
And so over here,
we have laid out
very roughly the
different stages
of constructing that model.
But along that way, there
is a variety of questions
that data scientists
would be asking.
And these are questions
that have come up
in the UX research
and other initiatives
that we've been
doing in the past,
such as when you're doing
your data preprocessing, one
of the questions you
might ask is well,
what preprocessing
techniques should I use?
When I move over to the next
couple of stages of the model
design and being able to tune
those parameters, the questions
that those users would
ask would be, well,
what techniques
should I be using?
If I'm doing deep-learning,
which architecture
should I be selecting and
what sort of hyperparameters
should I be tuning?
And then once you move
over to the evaluate step,
then it starts to get
into this whole goal
around being able to
analyze that data,
like understanding what metrics
are most important or most
relevant to my objective.
How do I know that my model's
actually performing well?
What are some ways for me
to actually improve my data
set so that if I
were to retrain,
it would actually
produce better results?
And then for deployment, then
there is a question around,
what infrastructure
should I be using
to be able to serve
this model at scale?
Or how do I meet my
overall latency goals?
And then there's this
process of updating.
And then that cycles back
to the previous step.
And so you might end up asking
these questions multiple times
as you're starting to go through
and improve your data set.
And as you're answering these
questions along the way,
that could start to get
pretty expensive as you're
starting to choose all
these different pathways
and see what combinations work
best and produces the best
outcome.
And then any time that you were
to, say, change your objective
or shift it around,
then you have
to start over from the
beginning in many cases.
So what we started to
look at with AutoML
is being able to take
all those complex steps
of building a ML model and being
able to automate it somehow.
And the way that
we'll show it is we'll
see how it manifests
in a user interface.
But what the goal
of AutoML at that
point is that it allows you to
focus on actually collecting
the right data and being able
to define the right business
objectives and still
have a model that's
of high enough quality that you
can deploy it to production.
And so the workflow
that then manifests
gets distilled
down to, well, you
put together your data set
with some training images
and labels.
You pass it into
AutoML, which will
do the whole process
of training your model,
deploying your model, and
serving your model on Google
Cloud.
And then what you end up with
is a simple REST interface
for making those
types of predictions.
So what types of capabilities
does AutoML currently
have or AutoML Vision
currently have?
Well, we have single-label
classification.
So this is the case where you
might have an image that should
be only one of several classes.
So the example that
we bring up here
is one where you're trying to
distinguish different cloud
types from each other based on
the overall physical properties
or visual properties
of these clouds.
And this could be
one of those inputs
to help build a pretty good
indication of what the weather
is going to be like.
The other side of it would
be multilabel classification
where an image can
have several classes.
So one example
might be maybe you
want to create this
giant latte art database.
And you have all these
different indicators
of what types of properties
this latte art should have.
And maybe at some point
you want to-- when
people upload new images
of their latte art,
they can automatically
categorize and easily browsable
and all that.
But this would be a case where
you would not necessarily
want feather to win out
over latte or etching
to win out over mocha.
But rather, it's
like they would also
share those common properties.
So what happens under the hood
is that AutoML can actually
use AI to build AI.
So what we mean by that is
that we actually introduce--
once you submit your
data set to AutoML,
an AI agent will come in and be
able to build this model that
uses deep learning
techniques that
has the optimal architecture and
set of hyperparameters to solve
your particular business need.
And where that manifests,
like back in April,
there was this
article that came out
that showed this Japanese
researcher that was
able to take photos of ramen.
And there's this shop
called Ramin Jiro.
They have 40-some locations.
And what this researcher was
able to do is take, I believe,
1,000 photos from
each of those shops
and then be able to
pass that into AutoML,
train it for about 24 hours.
And when all was
said and done, it
was able to predict which
specific shop that ramen came
from with something like a 95%
accuracy, that being 94 point
something percent recall or
94 point something percent
precision.
So that was an
interesting case because I
myself an a giant ramen fan.
So I was kind of a--
[LAUGHTER]
It's very rare that articles
about AI make you salivate.
But it was-- that would
be one of a couple.
But anyway.
So where UX starts
to get involved
is this whole process
of creating user stories
and scenarios.
And so we'll start
with a simple one.
So we'll start with this user.
We'll call her Jane.
She's a developer at a
wildlife conservancy.
Maybe she's familiar
with Cloud Vision API.
But she's probably familiar with
implementing APIs in general.
She happens to have a
lot of images on hand.
But she has little
direct ML experience.
She's more of an ML enthusiast.
And so, unfortunately, this
photo is a little washed out.
But that's a little silhouette
of a flightless bird
right there.
So what she wants to do is
create a bird classifier
so she can improve
the experience
of her ornithology app.
So maybe what ends
up happening is
she ends up using the Vision
API, the pretrained Vision API,
to handle a lot of her labeling
techniques or labeling tasks.
But in the case of being
able to distinguish emus
from cassowaries, from
rheas to ostriches,
she wants to create an even more
custom model to address that.
And so what would be some
ways that she might do this?
Well, there's a couple
of different approaches.
One is that she could use
this Wizard of Oz approach,
where when users submit
images, she'll surreptitiously
take these images and send
them to a human labeling pool
somewhere that will go in and
label these images for her
and send it back.
And then this gets
indexed by the database.
But you can see
where this starts
to get not all that scalable
in the long run, where
the cost will increase
as the number of users
increases, the number of--
if she decides to expand
her reach beyond just
these four classes, then
that starts to complicate
how she interacts
with this labeling service.
And if she wants results
in a matter of seconds
rather than minutes
or days, then this
is probably not the
right solution for her.
Another possibility is that
she could use the Vision API.
But as mentioned
earlier, these categories
may not necessarily be
all that specific enough
to meet her use case.
The third option, which we
brought up a few slides back,
is that she could
write a model herself.
But as mentioned by her
persona description,
she doesn't have
the ML expertise
to do to build that model.
So what we offer as
the ultimate solution
is to use AutoML Vision,
where Google can basically
train a model off of her
own images and labels.
And so this is where
we get into a demo.
And hopefully, this will work.
So as a setup, I had created
a folder called birds
on the left.
And within there, I
create four folders
with the different
labels that I want.
And then within each
of those folders,
I just threw in all
the images that I want
labeled ostrich or emu or rhea.
So if I can go here--
I'll go here.
And this is the AutoML
Vision interface.
This is me creating
a new data set.
So I can go here and say,
OK, I'll call this birds.
And from here, I can
import my images.
And there's three
different options.
So one option is the one that
is suited for my purpose, which
is to basically just upload
these images from my computer
where I just select these files.
And I'll say, OK.
I'll take this
birds [INAUDIBLE]..
And I'll pop in like so.
The other main
option that we have
is that you can select a CSV
file on Google Cloud Storage.
And this would be
particularly useful
if you have an inordinately
large amount of images,
in which case you might want
to use Google Cloud Storage's
tools in order to get
massive numbers of images
into your data set.
The other possibility
is that maybe you
want to control the
training validation testing
split, in which
case you can specify
what bucket it should go into
within the CSV file itself.
And so there's a
little code over here
that describes how that
search syntax works, where
you have the path to the
location of your image
on Google Cloud Storage.
And then you follow
it with a comma
and then put the label
or labels after it.
And then if you wanted
to specify whether it's
in training,
validation, or testing,
then you would prepend that
line with training, validation,
or test.
And so this is more for users
that are maybe a little bit
more advanced,
that would know how
data splitting works and have
best practices around it.
So we don't
necessarily surface it
at this point, given that we
handle the split automatically
if they just leave
it empty for now.
And then the third
option is that they
can import their images later.
So they essentially start
with an empty data set.
And then they can, through
the interface itself,
they can throw in their
images and label them--
label them manually
within the UI
or use the human
labeling service
that's also built into the UI.
And then this last
option over here
is just basically
specifying what
the classification type is.
So it's single-label
classification by default.
But you can optionally
choose to make
this multi-label classification.
So at this point, I would
hit Create Data Set.
And then it would churn
for some amount of time.
It depends on the
size of your data set.
But I think for this
one, it took probably
about 20 or 30 minutes or so.
But we're not going to
wait 20 or 30 minutes here
because I don't really
have a whole lot
to say during that time.
So what I'll end up
doing is I'll just
skip over to the actual
created data set here.
So, hopefully, this works.
So my internet connection has
been kind of wonky all day.
So we'll see.
So here, this is after
I upload my zip file
through that Create Form.
And 20 or 30 minutes later, it
pops in this browser over here.
And so I can see all the
images that were imported
and the labels that are
associated with them over here.
And furthermore,
what I can do is
I can narrow it down
to a specific label
here by clicking on
this item over here.
So I narrowed that to
just the cassowaries.
They'd be over here.
And I see my ostriches.
And what I can
also do is I can go
in to individual images
over here and say, you know,
this particular
image right here?
Let's say, hypothetically,
that this wasn't an emu.
It was actually an ostrich.
I can go in here and say,
this is an ostrich, hit OK.
And then it will
update that data set.
So you can go in one by one
and updates these images,
or you can select it over here.
And you can do a click--
you can do the click select
or do a multiselect over here
to do multiple images,
and hit the label button
and do a mass relabeling
of these images to say,
for example, emu.
So it's all of built in here.
And it's also built to handle
a large list of labels as well.
So you have access to
filtering over here.
So I can filter down to
cassowaries this way.
Or I can search select on here.
There's a filter over here.
So it's geared
towards like being
on the order of 100, a couple
hundred labels that you can
potentially have in this case.
Once I move over
to the Train tab,
this would be the next step.
And at this point,
ordinarily I'd
be prompted with a
product call to action
to allow me to
train a new model.
So I click on this guy.
And I can say, OK,
this is my model.
And I'll give it a one
compute hour training
budget, which is free for the
first 10 models for each month.
I also have the
option of specifying
a larger number of
compute hours, which
we'll get to later.
And so once you submit
your training request,
it'll churn for
another amount of time.
And I think in this case, it
took about 15 to 20 minutes
or so and produced a model
that looks something like this.
I actually trained two
models this morning.
Actually, this one performed
slightly better than this one.
So the results that
I get is that I get
an average precision of 0.947.
And if I were one that
was not accustomed
to these particular values,
I might look at this tool tip
and say, OK, what does
this 0.9 whatever mean?
And so then if over here it says
that 1.0 is the maximum score,
so that means that's it's
looking pretty good right now.
My precision and recall
are good, but not great.
So maybe what I'll
do is I'll take
a look at the full evaluation
and see what's going on.
And so clicking that See
Full Evaluation takes me
to the third tab in this list,
which is the Evaluate tab.
And from here, I can take a
look at the All Labels panel
and get a deeper dive into
these precision recall graphs.
So I can move my
score threshold around
and see how that affects the
precision recall graph as well
as the precision at 1
and recall at 1 graph.
So for a more
advanced ML user, they
could see here what threshold
would make the best trade off
between precision and recall.
Or if they wanted to anchor
it more towards recall,
they can move it
over here, which
would produce more as false
positives as [INAUDIBLE]..
And then if I were
to move it over here,
then it would anchor it
more towards precision.
An then down below here,
there's a confusion matrix.
So this gives you a four
by four of the true labels
versus the predicted labels.
And when I look
at this over here,
I can see that for
cassowary and emu,
it actually performed
pretty well.
For ostrich, it performed OK.
85% is good but not
particularly great.
But it really suffered
on the rhea class.
And so it looks like it confused
rhea with ostrich quite a bit.
And having looked at birds
for the last couple of days--
[LAUGHTER]
--it seems that rheas, indeed,
although they're a much smaller
bird and they come from
a different continent--
I believe they're from South
America as opposed to Africa--
they look astonishingly
like ostriches.
And that was a thing I
was not entirely aware of.
So if I go over here, I can
see a specific precision recall
curve for this particular label.
And I can see the
list of true positives
that came back for
this particular label.
So these are all
different rheas.
And I can see some of
the false negatives.
So this would be photos that
were properly identified
as rheas but were not above that
0.50 score threshold that I had
specified up here.
And then down here are some
false positives that I got.
So these are ones where
it was labeled rhea but--
these are ostrich photos.
But we ended up predicting
rhea for whatever reason.
And like in this case, like
this is clearly an ostrich.
But for whatever reason,
the rhea label sort of
edged it out for
whatever reason.
And that whatever
reason is where
building that intuition around
how this model is working
starts to allow
these to formulate
some interesting
follow-up actions on
like, what should they do
next to improve their model?
So one option that
they could potentially
do is one that we say up
here is that basically,
if you were to add more
images to your data sets,
this would probably allow
you to improve your model.
And if I look at my
label stats, I actually
only uploaded just a
couple hundred images
for each of these labels.
And as it turns out
for cassowary and emu,
I mean, maybe this might
suffice because like it
seems to perform pretty well.
But for ostrich,
I had 400 images.
And for rhea, I
only had 200 images.
Maybe I should add
more rhea images
in order to see if I
can get my metrics up.
Another possibility
that I might want to do
is just take a look
at these images
and see maybe I
might have mislabeled
some of these images.
And so like in this
case, like this one was--
the ground truth is an ostrich.
But I think this
is actually a rhea.
And I think maybe I just went
and mislabeled these images.
So another thing that
I could potentially do
is backtrack to the
Images tab over here
and go to my rhea
section and basically
scan through and
see if all of these
are rheas and then, likewise,
go to my ostrich section
and see if any of
these are mistakenly
identified as rheas when they
should really be ostriches.
So this could be something
that maybe I might do.
Or it's something that I could
offload to a coworker of mine.
Maybe it's something that I can
export this data set to a CSV
file and look at this offline.
There's a couple of different
ways to go about that.
And then the last option
that you could potentially do
is basically throw more
compute hours at this model.
So we only trained it
with one compute hour,
which actually translates to
about 15 to 30 minutes or so.
But if I were to,
say, train a new model
and give it a much more
substantial training budget,
it's quite possible that
throwing more computer hours
will give me a better
model with the same data.
But this is something
that you can max out on,
but you can also customize.
You can say, maybe I just
wanted to try out two at first
and then see how things perform.
And then I can go back
and resume training
with an additional
set of compute hours.
So there's a couple
of different options
at my disposal as far as going
in and intervening and seeing
if I can squeeze better
performance out of this model.
And then the last step
that the user can do
is go to this Predict section.
This is sort of like
the moment of truth
where they can click this
button and upload some hold out
images.
So I have this image over here.
This appears to be an emu.
So we'll see if this
thing will actually work.
And, yeah.
It looks like it predicted
an emu with 0.996% score.
Ostrich was slightly
represented,
rhea slightly represented.
But it's almost so infinitesimal
that it might not even
matter all that much.
And if I had set the
score threshold at 0.5,
then this would be graded
as an emu, regardless.
And then down below, we have
a couple of code samples
that will allow you to
implement your custom model.
So we provide some
snippets for the REST API.
And you can toggle over here
to see a little mini Python
script so that you can--
if you're a person
that happens to have
a lot of training images on
hand but maybe not necessarily
a lot of programming experience,
you can take this guy
and copy it and paste it and
send it to your web developer
and say, hey, can
you help out here
and see if you can get
this thing to work?
But in the meantime, the model
itself has been deployed to
and is readily available
for predictions.
So that's basically the long
and short of the workflow.
And so let me just go
back to the presentation.
And so from here,
we can conjure up
some ideas on how all
this fits together,
like different pieces.
So unfortunately,
there's a boundary
that circles these four
boxes in the center.
But that represents the
Google Cloud Platform system.
And so one workflow
that you can imagine
is that maybe a user uploads
new images from their computer.
It gets sent into
Google Cloud Platform.
It gets stored on Cloud
Storage, which will then
trigger a new image notification
via the Pub/Sub Google Cloud
product, which then gets sent
to App Engine, which is what
the search index is based on.
And what can happen there is
that, well, App Engine could
call the AutoML
Vision API and say,
OK, I got these
three new images.
What do these images look like?
And the AutoML Vision API can
return back predictions on,
well, this is an ostrich, this
is an emu, this is a rhea,
and store that in a
search index on App Engine
so that in step five, the user
can search for, say, ostrich
or rhea and be able
to get those results
automatically tagged
on their behalf.
Now let's take a step back
and take a deeper dive
into the user experience.
So user experience or UX is
in the most general terms,
at least at Google, loosely
split into these three
different branches.
So there's UX research, UX
design, and UX prototyping.
And you see that one
feeds into the other.
And there's actually
some hidden arrows where
it cycles back in on itself.
So as like a primer
on what these three
different disciplines are, so
UX research is all about better
understand the problem space.
And that could be through
interviews with stakeholders,
with customers, doing
academic research,
being able to gather insights
from a whole spectrum
of sources, being able to
provide meaningful analysis
and also interpret the results
so that it can be translated
into actionable steps,
not just for UX design
and prototyping but also for
the product management team,
for engineering, et cetera.
But as far as the scope
of this discussion,
the primary artifacts
from UX research
feed into UX design, which is
the area that I'm rooted in.
And that's all
around constructing
the flows, the overall
user journey, the way
that the product is constructed
from a visual and information
hierarchy standpoint.
It can also encompass visual
design and motion design,
so things like transitions or
web components are being used
and how they look like,
the aesthetics are
all part of that kind of realm.
Then that feeds
into UX prototyping,
also known as UX
engineering at Google.
And that is the ability to take
all these design and research
artifacts and encapsulating it
into something that's tangible
that we can show to
stakeholders, to other team
members--
be it as a spec or
as a demonstration--
or most importantly,
in our case,
to UX research participants.
So this gives us an
early look at how
the design is going
without necessarily getting
too deep into the
implementation side of things.
And the way that prototyping
manifests within the UX field
is that it takes a variety of
different levels of fidelity.
Like it can range from
very low fidelity,
like just a series
of pieces of paper
that have a bunch
of diagrams on it,
that you just show in
sequence, kind of mixed around.
It could be something
like a Google Slides
deck or a PowerPoint deck where
it's like a series of mock ups.
They take a participant through
or a stakeholder through.
But then it can-- again, to
the very high fidelity where
it's actually a semi-interactive
or fully interactive product
that a participant can directly
interact with and see how
does this meet
their expectations.
And so one way
that this manifests
is here on AutoML, where
this is like the live demo
that I showed right here.
This other tab right
here is the UX prototype
that we've been building
over the last however long.
And this is basically something
that is using not real data,
but it's using as many UX
patterns and components
put together to see how that
maps to users' expectations
and allows us to get a head
start on how our design
thinking is going without
leaping directly into bugging
a bunch of engineers to make a
bunch of back end and front end
modifications that may
end up not testing well.
And so in this case, you
can see that there's--
this is all fairly functional.
You can go in and select
a bunch of images.
You can assign some labels
and do all sorts of activities
that you would normally
do with a live product.
But this is all done all through
smoke and mirrors essentially.
And it's basically more or less
like an inherently disposable
tool that we can use to do
some rapid iterations on.
So one example, which,
unfortunately, will not
show up particularly
well on this screen,
was with a confusion
matrix where we originally
had started off
with a matrix that
looks like this, where the
positive values or the matches
were green.
The negative ones were red.
But a concern came up
that people with red/green
colorblindness may
not necessarily
see that diagonal strip of
green in the center there.
It's actually looks all like
shades of yellow or brown.
So what we ended up doing
was use this prototype
as a means of being able to try
out a couple of different color
palettes, so like
being able to see,
oh, OK, let's see what it looks
like with a blue-gray themed.
We ultimately settled on the
blue-orange theme over here
because it gives a fair amount
of prominence between the two.
But the ability
that we can toggle
between these different variants
without necessarily impacting
the rest of the flow
or having to crank out
a bunch of additional mockups
was one of the key pieces
that we got out of this one.
Another quick example
is like looking
at one of these images of here.
You can see the
predictions on the right.
But one thing that we
we're thinking about, well,
what if we were to just tweak
the layout so that we want
this column to appear on the
left-hand side as opposed
to making a request through
to our friend engineers, like,
try this out, see how it feels.
We can just try it
out on the side,
see where the pros and cons
of this particular layout--
do things become more
readable, less readable?
How does this align
with how they've
interacted with previous
products in the Google
Cloud, et cetera?
So if I jump back
to the presentation
here, so as we started to do
a series of these iterations,
we had multiple
rounds of testing
on the research side, which
led to a bunch of iterations
on the design side, which
on the prototyping side.
A series of UX schools
start to emerge.
And I have a couple of examples
of where in the workflow
these goals manifest.
So the first one
was all around being
able to ground the
users' mental model.
And what that means
is that we end up
taking the traditional
ML workflow, which, yes,
is a semilinear process
but has this tendency
to circle back in on
itself, where once you
get to a certain point after,
say, evaluating your model,
you may circle back and
label some more images
and then go back through
this process again.
But eventually, the
goal is to end up
at the very last step
over here and start
to see what are the different
subtasks or user stories that
align with these
different themes that are
part of each of these steps.
So it might be something that's
fairly straightforward like,
well, as a user, I want to name
the data sets so that I can
recall later, whereas
the user wants
to specify whether this is
single-label classification
or multilabel classification.
On the import side to--
on the other side,
as a user, I want
to be able to access
code samples so
that I can be able to implement
my model and deploy it.
And where we start to see
some sort of consolidation
was seeing if we can map these
different steps of the workflow
to specific states within
the application itself.
And so where that starts to
come to play is-- unfortunately,
it's a little washed out, but--
the idea that there is
a Create Form over here
at the left, which
leads to this tab
set over here that
encompasses these four steps.
And you can toggle between
Images, Train Evaluate,
and Test and Use, or predict.
Because they're tabs,
you can navigate
backwards and forwards.
So here's-- maybe a
little bit easier to see,
or there's the Create Form.
And then over here, you see
the images on the top left--
Train, Evaluate, and Predict--
representing those
four stages of the ML
flow that you can go back
in any particular order
and jump forward in
any particular order.
There's no requirement
to do all of the steps.
But there's still
this forward momentum
that propels you towards
this last step over here.
Another piece that
came to the forefront
was being able to educate
users on new concepts.
And by "new," I
mean new to users
that have little ML expertise.
And so this would
be something that
might be around
progressive disclosure,
so like the tool tip that I
showed earlier where it's like,
well, average precision is
this weird, foggy concept
to people that might
not have ML expertise.
And then precision recall,
they sound intuitive.
But maybe we need to
provide some additional text
to help bring more clarity
to this particular term.
And so this is
something that we've
been doing a couple of
subsequent iterations
on to see if we can make
this language increasingly
clear to people that might
struggle with understanding
these broad concepts.
And so it's something
that we're--
it's still a work in progress.
Additionally, things
like distinguishing
between a false negative
and a false positive
would be areas that we
would investigate more fully
in the detailed view where we
showed the list of predictions.
So here, we have a list
of labels and the scores
they received.
But then we also
indicate which one
was the ground truth by
this little star over here
and indicate, well, this label
because it was above 0.5--
which was the score
threshold that you had set--
and it was not the
ground truth, we're
deeming it as a false positive.
And then meanwhile,
this one that's
below 0.5, that star
is false negative.
So trying to reintroduce
these concepts over and over
again through the product itself
is another thing that we're
trying to do to produce a more--
infuse more user education
directly into the UI.
So that's AutoML Vision
more or less in a nutshell.
And we have two
other products as
mentioned earlier that
launched at Next as well.
So we have AutoML
Natural Language,
which is essentially like
the same principle as AutoML
Vision.
But it's dealing basically with
free form, unstructured text
like documents.
And the use cases
around that are--
there's a variety of them
that are associated with that.
And then down below, we
have AutoML Translation,
which is more about being
able to take the existing
Translation API and
being able to augment it
with your specific use cases.
So if there are certain needs
or certain words or idioms,
pieces of vernacular that
the current Translation
API is struggling with, if you
have a whole series of sample
sentence pairs, you can pass
that into AutoML Translation
and build a custom
model for that.
So you can find out
more about AutoML
by going to this link, which
is actually repeated over here.
And this is also an opportunity
to promote our office hours.
So if you have a lot of
questions around the underlying
technology for AutoML or want to
find out more about how AutoML
works under the
hood, it's possible
that through office
hours, we can pair you up
with somebody that might
have more of that knowledge
base on there.
All right.
Well, thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]